[music]
manin from the pen of signals and without
Shpilevsky you pull years not heavy rain
but from hell the essence of memory burst while you
saw stories stink from the little finger
[music]
[applause]
mini ,
[music]
will  and also my daughter was
notified with shami and the combat hologram is
now heading to the park of partisan
glory, it is called there there are several
lakes from the moon and the side, well, a very place where
you can bring the race and in the summer they described all the
leagues there don’t stand where sticking out the idol
another match you know the cafe world is
the first
by aura jeans miss g to pg-13 about
history
this is kiev yes yes city center this is one of the
places where I put an easel this is here
[music]
all videos
here we draw saved a cool place here I am
as an artist from myself  positioning for seven
years I was an economist lawyer case
successful career
writer 108 years
that's harmony it's blocks i
'm wrong terence
8 professional
apple ios scape
[music]
yeah that's all my
work this is my favorite job i
call immersion immersion in
relation to immersing people in each other
here recognize a person goes deep to the
very bottom and who  -something without leaving pai ai
became in the inte committee up to 100 and dudes
they were juanita speak up
didn’t go
but for more than 5 years
I got married here for the first time kiwi
and I had a daughter July who is
now 20 years old whose children I lost
this association  we
lived for 8 years already from our second marriage, we didn’t have children
very much, so we
used
IVF and we got
twins
, my father died in my arms, we have
cancer, I was engaged in denunciation
against the background of such events of the day,
but you didn’t  children were born
[music]
then I gave birth, but here is a girl who I
have the youngest daughter who is xenia who
was well, 6 months old who died at
birth,
I have
to go
[music]
[applause]
I didn’t sleep I didn’t eat some mane
didn’t communicate with people and advised my husband
to heal in a hospital, by the way, I
didn’t get there thanks to one person
thanks thanks chica and you are now in
place well but you won’t be there
at first I went half a year Vohma grandfather  to the
intensive care unit with my own
as well as the road to the shelf before I reach the
video of the
next five
it was the wish of our family
priest to give up drugs not
to go to the doctor but to go to the nets every
morning and for the whole day I have been on this road
for more than five years and therefore
I think  with their closed eyes they can
drive along and across I know it, therefore,
like this
[music
] this icon near which the
Mother of God probably cried most and most often
does not seem to be here and that
turning point in my life happened and here you
practically became the restoration of
me as an artist yes  first an icon painter,
then an artist,
my father print suggested that you
can come on, although I used to, first I
started here  at home pictures there flowers
such something draw said let
me show and you will bookmark me here icon
[music]
shares apple
of speaking of it doesn't interest
but kinds of thy will make you feel my
love
they feels like
[music]
let's sleep with you direct speech  about the pure
love of Christ's stand, the topic became
therapy
at first as icons, and therefore the berry itself
ran after her works, the works themselves, I
forgot,
but those problems that I had.
so
I'm tired of on metal.
they saw
him white rice glad to dig both
shows dis-moi flames
[music]
buns